We are here to learn, which means that we
might have to admit that we don't know everything.
We can't just try to justify our own beliefs,
but, instead, we must humble ourselves and
be willing to hear other people out, willing
to be wrong, willing to swallow our pride
and shift our views.
Because being a Hillsdalian means doing whatever
it takes to pursue truth.
The best gift that you can give to this institution
and certainly the best gift that you can give
any person is your unreserved, enthusiastic,
and joyful self.
You can learn nothing at any moment when you
are not working, and just as bad, you cannot
help others if you do not prepare.
That's why you have been warned that this
not easy.
We here, the faculty over there, we love you.
Why?
It's so much fun to watch you.
Everything you do you're doing for the first
time, including this and this day.
I welcome you with the words that I have said
now 17 times as the last words I say at this
ceremony: get your boots on.
Welcome.